it's a millionaire theme our on the Dave
Ramsey show we're talking to real
millionaires and finding out how they
did it so that you can do what they've
done
Wayne's whether Swain is in st. Louis hi
Wayne how are you doing great good what
is your net worth sir probably 1.75
million cool and what is that invested
in sir retirement accounts mutual funds
is majority of it about 1.1 real estate
approximately four hundred sixty-five
thousand and the rest is my emergency
fund savings mm-hmm so what's your home
worth about 350 cool good for you man
congratulations how old are you I'm 61
my wife's 57 all right neat and what was
your range of income through your
working lifetime or your average income
or something like that my average
between both of us probably 120 and 160
now I'm retired our incomes right around
142 144 mm-hmm
and how much of the 1.75 million did you
inherit we inherited some land from my
mother-in-law worth about a hundred
thousand and that was it okay so where
did this wealth come from just no debt
saving and just working together with my
spouse okay cool
and what was your career the two of you
I I retired from a major you till
December the TVA in your area and my
wife still works as in payroll
administration what did you do with the
utility I was working bulk
transmission buying in selling no kind
of in training okay all right cool all
right
and what was your degree in sir I had no
degree no degree okay cool what was your
GPA in high school I was uh probably
three something from between 3 and 3 5
okay all right all right cool so how
of the 1.75 million do you have because
you borrowed money to invest zero okay
you said earlier you didn't like debt
yeah so what part has giving played in
your financial plan through these years
well besides tithing you know I believe
in helping the others because we were
helping early on in our life I get
whenever and wherever I can to to help
others to kind of get started we've
coordinated a couple FPU classes and to
help people out we sponsored a lot of
those and just helping people where we
can well thank you for doing that that's
very nice what's the most expensive pair
of jeans you ever bought for me thirty
dollars
okay and more all right
and before you had a million dollars how
many brand new cars did you buy before
you had a million dollars probably three
okay all right cool very cool good good
so hmm interesting
what advice would you have to the
20-something version of you listening
right now I would say first you set
goals and get out debt as soon as
possible you say you systematically and
above all a 10-1 of they rented a PE
class thank you that's good thank you
appreciate the ad but so basically what
you guys have done is you've just lived
what's the best vacation you've ever had
we went on an Alaskan cruise probably
five years ago okay and that's probably
didn't know it was the best thing I'm
the motor gets them the best one of all
okay it's very cool what's the most fun
you have with money I think just sharing
with others that we see this in need
that's ours we get a real blessing out
about amen amen
very cool good for you sir hey man thank
you for calling in and for sharing this
show here oh I'm honored to talking to
you one question Dave yes sir I've been
asked to speak at a young couple retreat
at our church coming up next month
on
in Devon and I've known I think I know
what book I would recommend Tom but if
your books what would you recommend it
because I'm gonna buy each couple of
book what would you recommend for a
young couple just nearly married that's
very nice that's very generous of you
Total Money Makeover is the book we
recommend for them to start with well
that's when I had marked down I just
want to get confirm that yeah well thank
you again thank you for all of those
endorsements and appreciate who you are
as a person and how you've managed your
life and the creation of you know 1.75
million way to go man ding ding you're
on the belt hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income or $500,000 in
the company